[Musique]
[Rires]
quoi il ya beaucoup de personnes il ya
beaucoup de personnages ou tout parce
que ces gens là sont venus pour écouter
six comédiens alors et ses comédiens
en fait ils passent de ville en ville de
village en village pour jouer justement
de la musique lors comme tu dis ya
beaucoup de monde et quand on regarde en
détail ses personnages qu'est ce qu'on
voit il y à des personnages au centre
deux personnages principaux
avec un qui est en train de jouer d'un
instrument de musique c'est une sorte de
luth
en fait c'est un instrument de musique
marocains qu'on appelle une mandorle et
puis on peut imaginer que le personnage
qui est là au milieu avec cette grande
tunique noire va peut-être jouer dans
quelques instants du tambourin
[Musique]
lui n'avait jamais voyagé auparavant il
ne connaissait que paris et puis aussi
les villes autour de autour de paris ils
étaient même venus à tour d'ailleurs il
connaissait la touraine mais il n'était
jamais allé aussi loin
donc ils arrivent au maroc en 1832 il
arrive par bateau
il est absolument ébloui par ce qu'il
voit et ce qu'il va faire pour essayer
de garder le plus possible les souvenirs
de ce qu'il voit comme il est peintre
il va dessiner des tas de petits croquis
dans des carnets de dessins notamment tu
vois on a la chance ce musée d'avoir
deux dessins qui représentent le jeune
garçon que l'on voit à droite et ce
jeune garçon aussi aujourd'hui c'était
un marchand du ruban il avait peut-être
une quinzaine d'années il vendait des
rubans à tanger donc il va dessiner à
tous petits croquis au crayon de papier
qui fait peut-être sept centimètres de
haut
totalement inscrit deux peintres de la
cre en fait est un artiste romantique et
à partir du moment où il a séjourné au
maroc il est devenu artiste orientaliste
puisque le maroc à cette époque était en
fait un pays d'orient
les parisiens qui eux n'avaient pas la
chance de pouvoir faire effectuer ces
grands voyages il était absolument
séduit par ce qu'ils voyaient par ses
tableaux
c'est une époque il ne faut pas
l'oublier il n'y avait pas par exemple
la photographie on ne connaissait pas la
photographie l'art comment pouvoir avoir
une idée de la manière dont les choses
se déroulaient dans ces pays qui était
quand même très loin et bien par ses
tableaux finalement on avait des images
qui représentait finalement le quotidien
de tous ces gens qui vivaient très très
loin de paris et ça ça intéresser
énormément les parisiens
[Musique]
il
m
[Musique]